welcome back to cbs this morning an
all-out push by democrats for a massive
overhaul of u.s elections
has reached the senate after being
passed in the house senators held a
hearing yesterday on the so-called
for the people act the bill would expand
early voting and allow for universal
mail-in voting
the measure comes as 43 states consider
republican-backed proposals
to curb voting rights hours require
stricter id checks on mailed in ballots
and
limit where the ballots can be returned
nowhere is the issue of voting rights
more urgent than
in the state of georgia our ed o'keefe
spoke with leaders there about this
fight
if your vote didn't matter they wouldn't
be working so hard to try to stop it so
don't let anybody take your voice or
your vote
senator rafael warnock will be up for
re-election next year when georgia will
also have a competitive governor's race
it certainly has been a very interesting
time that's part of what's fueling an
especially partisan fight
over voting rights in the peach state
georgia is ground zero
for the voting rights debate and
it is difficult to overstate how
important this issue is
the republican-controlled legislatures
putting the final touches on changes to
state voting laws that would mandate new
early voting hours
enact stricter id laws for absentee
voting
and potentially even regulate who can
talk to voters
standing in long lines it's part of a
nationwide push by republicans in the
wake of former president trump's laws
that he's actively encouraging another
one of the most
urgent issues facing the republican
party
is that of ensuring fair honest
and secure elections
[Music]
georgia state senate president pro tem
butch miller is among those
pushing for the changes we have a lack
of confidence
in the ballot box and the integrity of
the ballot box
and we have to restore that would
republicans be doing this if donald
trump had won
in november let me look at my crystal
ball
miller says he and his gop colleagues
have received thousands of calls from
constituents concerned about the
election results
we had people call that said that they
received multiple ballots in the mail
they received multiple requests for
absentee ballots in the mail
if you get one in the mail you don't
know where it came from did you but if
it says
state of georgia on the on the envelope
as its mail
you're telling me there are people who
are concerned that that might not be a
legitimate ballot there might be people
that are concerned about that and
rightfully so
warnock strongly disagrees if there's
any lack of confidence
in our voting system it's because
politicians have been pushing the big
lie
they are using the lie about voter fraud
as a pretext for voter suppression
this is jim crow redux in new clothes
there is no reason for this what we saw
was
black voters all across the country
standing up
other voters of color young people women
students
and they made a difference in the
election
to those who call it jim crow 2.0 or jim
crow in a suit and tie you say
that is just sad that someone would
stoop
to that type of name calling we want
everybody to have a chance to vote
stopping the republican-backed changes
to election laws is of concern to
national democrats like warnock
and president biden they met last week
to discuss the subject with other
georgia democrats
during the president's visit to atlanta
do you think republicans would be
pushing to make these changes
if you had lost your election last year
well the fact is i won
and i won as a result
of more than a decade
of active engagement right here on the
ground in georgia
as the senate continues debating voting
rights the president admitted to
democratic senators this week to some of
the changes they want to make things
like mandating
automatic voter registration or
expanding early and absentee voting to
all states nationwide
could be difficult to get done in the
closely divided senate
unless they change the rules anthony and
it's not just the politicians feeling
the pressure though it's the
corporations too
that's right big employers in georgia
like coca-cola delta airlines home depot
ups all of them facing pressure from
voting rights groups
democrats in the state saying you know
you should be speaking out about this
because corporate pressure often can
influence a debate
the georgia chamber of commerce says
they support accessible and secure
voting while upholding election
integrity
and transparency it's a pretty neutral
statement there we'll see
one other thing that state senator
miller pointed out real quick he says
this legislative process
is quote like a stew and it cooks real
slow
the point being there were a lot of
proposals yeah very few of them are
going to make it into the final dish
that gets served up to the governor
i'm getting hungry now ed thank you